♪
>> Lawrence: WE HAVE A FOX NEWS
ALERT THE DESPERATE SEARCH FOR
ANSWERS CONTINUE IN THE CASE OF
THE MISSING 22-YEAR-OLD GABBY
PETINO.
WE HAVE NEW VIDEO OF SEVERAL
POLICE OFFICERS CURRENTLY AT THE
HOME OF HER FIANCE, A PERSON OF
INTEREST, BRIAN LAUNDRIE.
FOX NEWS CARLEY SHIMKUS IS AT
THE SCENE AND SHE JOINS US LIVE
IN FLORIDA WITH THE LATEST.
CARLEY, WHAT DO YOU KNOW?
AT THE SCENE BEHIND YOU.
>> Carley: YES, THERE IS A LOT
OF MOVEMENT HAPPENING RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE A POLICE OFFICER JUST
WALKED OUT OF THE LAUNDRIE
FAMILY HOUSE.
ARE INSIDE.
FAMILY AT THE FAMILY'S REQUEST.
THEY ARE NOT TALKING TO BRIAN,
THEY ALSO SAY THAT MORE
INFORMATION IS TO COME ON THAT
FRONT.
POLICE ARRIVED AT THE HOUSE A
LITTLE OVER AN HOUR AGO.
THREE POLICE OFFICERS WALKED N
QUICK SUCCESSION.
NO KNOCK ON THE DOOR.
THEY JUST WALKED RIGHT IN, WHICH
SUGGESTS THAT THE FAMILY KNEW
THAT THEY WERE COMING.
ANOTHER POLICE OFFICER ARRIVED
ABOUT 15 MINUTES AGO.
HE WAS CARRYING A BROWN PAPER
BAG.
IT WAS EMPTY.
IT COULD POSSIBLY BE AN EVIDENCE
BAG.
WITH YOU LIKE I SAID, I COULDN'T
GET A SIGNIFICANT ENOUGH LOOK AT
THE BAG TO TELL YOU WITH CERTAIN
AT THIS WHAT IT WAS.
SPEAKING OF SIGNIFICANCE, THIS
IS THE MOST SIGNIFICANT MOVEMENT
IN THE CASE SO FAR.
I WAS HERE THIS MORNING,
YESTERDAY MORNING, THE HOUSE WAS
COMPLETELY DARK.
THE BIGGEST THING THAT HAPPENED
THIS MORNING IS THAT SOMEBODY
TURNED ON A LIGHT, WHICH PROVED
THAT PEOPLE WERE INSIDE THE
HOUSE.
SOME PEOPLE STARTED TO WONDER IF
THE FAMILY WAS INSIDE BECAUSE
PEOPLE HADN'T SEEN THEM FOR A
WHILE.
THE FIRST TIME POLICE CAME TO
THE LAUNDRIE FAMILY HOUSE WAS ON
SEPTEMBER 11TH WHEN GABBY'S MOM
FILED A MISSING PERSON'S REPORT
AND POLICE WERE MET BASICALLY
WITH NOTHING.
MOM AND DAD CAME TO THE DOOR.
BRIAN'S PARENTS CAME TO THE
DOOR, HANDED THEM A PIECE OF
PAPER THAT BASICALLY SAID TALK
TO OUR LAWYERS.
AND THAT'S HOT POLICE HAVE BEEN
BASICALLY COMMUNICATING WITH
EVER SINCE.
BRIAN HAS NOT SPOKEN OUT.
THERE IS ANOTHER SIGNIFICANT
DEVELOPMENT THAT BROKE ABOUT AN
HOUR AGO AS WELL.
GRAND COUNTY UTAH POLICE SAID
THERE IS NO LINK BETWEEN THE
DISAPPEARANCE OF GABBY PETINO
AND THE DOUBLE HOMICIDE THAT
TOOK PLACE THAT NEWLY WED COUPLE
BOTH IN MOAB, UTAH IF YOU
RECALL.
THERE WAS A POLICE -- POLICE
CAME TO MOAB AND SPOKE TO GABBY
AND BRIAN ON AUGUST 12TH BECAUSE
SOMEBODY CALLED THEM BECAUSE OF
A DISTURBANCE THAT TOOK PLACE,
TURNED OUT THEY HAD GOTTEN INTO
A PHYSICAL ALTERCATION BUT NO
CRIMINAL CHARGES WERE FILED.
POLICE HAVE GREATLY STRETCHED SO
FAR THROUGHOUT THIS WEEK THAT
BRIAN, WHILE HE IS A PERSON OF
INTEREST, THEY CAN'T PROVE ANY
CRIMINALITY THUS FAR.
AND HE HAS HIS RIGHT TO REMAIN
SILENT.
THAT RIGHT TO REMAIN SILENT HAS
ANGERED MANY PEOPLE BECAUSE MANY
HERE TODAY PROTESTERS INCLUDED,
BELIEVE THAT HE KNOWS SOMETHING
SIGNIFICANT ABOUT GABBY AND
COULD HAVE BEEN THE LAST PERSON
TO SEE HER, LAWRENCE.
>> Lawrence: CARLEY, DEFINITELY
PLAYING A SEMANTICS GAME TO
COVER THEIR TAIL AS WELL WHILE
THE INVESTIGATION PLAYS OUT.
I HEARD THERE IS A PROTEST AS
WELL OUT THERE, CARLEY.
SO I WILL BE CHECKING IN WITH
YOU THROUGHOUT THE NIGHT TO S